[Music]
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show so
big news at this hour joe biden finally
figured out who his vp pick
was going to be and then he forgot it
and then he remembered again
and then he sort of stumbled and then he
realized it was kamala harris so
very very exciting stuff kamala harris
the senator from california such a bad
candidate that she
jumped to the top of the field
immediately upon entering and then
completely flamed out
in a in a cataclysmic explosion
that truly rocked the entire
presidential campaign then when she left
everybody was like oh
no we need more black people in this
primary where did they all go
we loved kamala harris everybody's like
no we didn't but but we loved her
well now slow old joe
slo joe has picked kamala harris which
again i don't actually see the political
math on this one
she doesn't win him a state right
california's gonna win anyway
she has no traction in the black
community if she had had traction in the
black community
she wouldn't have dropped out before the
first primary joe biden has much more
traction in the black community than
kamala harris
ever did she is not moderate
she is not particularly a good debater
she likes to throw kind of single
punches and then
immediately flee from those punches
she's extraordinarily charmless on the
campaign trail
she is weirdly mechanical remember that
video of her like
fake laughing over the kamala harris
campaign bus which was then
decommissioned and turned into a
truancy bus so that she could go back to
her job as a.g
and in california and just arrest all
the truant students
the the uh the vicissitudes of politics
i'm old enough to remember as you are
i'm sure
i'm sure you're old enough to remember
when kamala harris attacked joe biden as
a vicious racist
that was good times remember that that
was like a year ago
well sadder times but now now they're
together again guys it's just a
it's an on off relationship here was
kamala harris calling joe biden an old
white racist
it's personal and it was actually very
it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race in
this country
and it was not only that but
you also worked with them to oppose
busing
and you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bused to school every day
and that little girl was me oh my god
that little girl was her and joe biden
would have kept her
from going to school evil joe biden who
she's now gonna run
for president with and then hope that he
plotted so that she can be president
like that's i mean let's be real about
this like she ain't taking the job
because she definitely wants to be vp
right
i mean like there's only one reason you
take that job with joe biden
that man is on his last legs in any case
kamala harris good times good times
and then you'll remember right after
that she went out in public and she was
like maybe joe should apologize to me
for what you remember this don't worry
guys she's not a rehearsed mechanical
viciously backbiting politician ever no
it's all good
to coddle the reputations of
segregationists
of people who if they had their way i
would literally not be standing here as
a member of the united states senate
is i think um it's just it's misinformed
and it's wrong
i apologize for that he's gonna have to
make that decision
but you know let's be very clear that
the the senators that he is speaking of
with such adoration are individuals who
made and built their reputation on
segregation
i mean that that is the person and also
also she also she loves him now
they're best friends now guys they're
just besties
so that's really exciting stuff and she
she really has
what a wonderful relationship they're
going to have together what a good time
they're going to have and don't worry
she's not radical
she's not radical in any way if you say
that she's a radical
it's only because you're you're not
being truthful she's not a radical
like for example she would never say she
wanted to ban fracking or something
like get rid of an incredibly powerful
domestic constituency
a major industry in the united states
that's actually lowered the carbon
emissions in the united states pretty
radically
she'd never say that thus damaging joe
biden's chances in some place like you
know pennsylvania
oh yeah wait wait here she is like last
year on cnn
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking so
yeah and and starting and starting with
what we can do on day one around public
lands
right and um and then there has to be
legislation but yes and this is
something i've taken on in california i
have a history of working on this issue
and to your point
um and you know that we have to just
acknowledge that the residual
impact of fracking is enormous in terms
of the impact on the health and safety
of communities
also she uh she would like to ban
plastic straws so that's exciting stuff
and just in case there's other things
like she wants to ban everything like
all the things she wants to be on she
wants to ban plastic straws that's
exciting stuff
your your future president kamal harris
do you ban plastic straws i think we
should
yes i mean look i'm going to be honest
it's really difficult to drink out of a
paper straw when you had if you're just
like if you don't gulp it down
immediately it starts to bend and then
and then you know the little thing
catches it and then you know but
so we got to kind of perfect that one a
little bit more
so you'd ban it but rely on innovation i
mean we got we got it
yeah innovation is it's a process right
you don't just
do it innovation is a process but but
you know
[Laughter]
that crazy laugh if you loved hillary's
laugh let me give you hillary 2.0
the laugh that that that's like
somewhere between
joaquin phoenix and heath ledger on the
joker skill of laughs so i'm i'm glad
that we
got rid of that in the primary so that
we can get it again during the general
that's exciting stuff also she wants to
create
federal incentives so americans can eat
less meat all this sounds fantastic to
me
a non-radical agenda from your pragmatic
moderate according to the ap
here's kamala harris being a pragmatic
moderate about not eating meat
the balance that we have to strike here
frankly is
about what government can and should do
around creating incentives
and then banning certain behaviors i
mean just to be very honest with you i
love cheeseburgers from time to time
right i mean i i just do and and i think
that um
but there is but there has to be also
what we do in terms of
creating incentives that we will eat in
a healthy way that we will encourage
moderation
and that we will be educated about the
effect of our eating habits
on our environment and we have to do a
much better job of that and the
government has to do a much better job
with that but at least she's moderate on
health care we know that because she
took every single position possible on
health care like all of them there are
no positions she did not take on health
care so during the primaries she first
suggested
suggested that she was for medicare for
all then she was like i'm not sure i'm
for medicare for all then she sort of
backed off her medicare for all thing
and then she was like well you know we
we shouldn't do medicare for all right
away because that means banning private
insurance but let's just kind of like
phase it out gradually so here she was
explaining that eventually private
insurance will go away
i believe the solution and i'm and i'm
actually feel very strongly about this
is that we need to have medicare for all
and you don't have to go through the
process of going through an insurance
company
having them give you approval going
through the paperwork all of the delay
that may require
who of us has not had that situation
where you got to wait for approval and
the doctor says well
i don't know if your insurance company
is going to cover this let's eliminate
all of that let's move on
we'll eliminate all of it like get rid
of private insurance who the hell needs
it who the hell needs it except for the
vast majority of americans who
like their private insurance uh in other
news you remember that time when in an
open debate she suggested that she would
ban assault weapon by executive order
that was a good one too i really liked
that one that was the one where joe
biden was specifically asked whether he
would ban
assault weapons and he said i can't do
that without congressional action and
kamala harris
did this weird thing where she was like
i guess well instead of saying no we
can't help but we say
ready for it yes we can
what a charmer she is she is just what
what an addition to the ticket
what in addition to the ticket and the
best thing is that she's a unifier
that's the really important thing about
her she's a deeply wonderful unifier
which is why very early on in the
campaign she suggested that she would
love to
campaign on the basis of identity
politics which is really exciting stuff
in fact she said that when people
complain about identity politics that's
just
them trying to shut people up this term
identity politics people will use that
term it's like
people used to talk about the race car
right and they'll bring this term up
when you talk about issues that are
about race about sexual orientation
about religion
they'll bring it up when we're talking
about civil rights issues
as a way to marginalize the issue as a
way to frankly
try to silence you or shut you up ah
is that is that what's happening here
she's a unifier guys she's a unifying
pragmatic moderate so it's kamala harris
that is who
joe biden finally settled on which is
deeply
shocking actually i mean i'm kind of
shocked it just does not seem like a
particularly smart pick but
maybe i'm wrong joining us online to
discuss is sean trendy of real clear
politics sean thanks so much for joining
the show appreciate it on short notice
hey thanks for having me so she was the
conventional wisdom pick i never
understood it
i don't see what she brings to the
ticket frankly she does not bring a
heavy level of black support
he skunked her with black support in the
primary she had so little black support
that she
never really got off the ground she had
this kind of early flare and then she
fell apart
she doesn't bring a state because
california is going to go for joe biden
by more votes than have ever been
created ever
she does not bring a real level of
political charm to the ticket because
she was widely perceived as
mechanical and manipulative during the
during the actual
campaign when she was when she was
running for president herself so can you
figure out for me
why he picked her other than he wanted
to check black and woman on the twitter
blue check boxes
well i think that's par a big part of it
he had pledged that he would put a woman
on the ticket
uh and so that narrowed down his choices
uh significantly and i think there was a
sense that there was
a low level of african-american support
or an enthusiasm for his campaign and
and
so once you've narrowed yourself down to
women and you figure you need a boost
among
african americans there were only four
or five choices to pick
from and and all them had their
downsides
well looking at the impact on the ticket
i mean as you say if the idea was that
he was going to boost
african-american turnout um i'm not sure
where she wasn't she wasn't super
popular with black americans again
in the primaries it seems like president
obama stumping for biden will probably
be more likely to raise
awareness in the black community of
voting for for biden or even opposition
to trump might raise that awareness
rather than than kamala harris
she does seem to bring some electoral
downsides i mean she for example i i was
noticing
in like a five minute search of my of my
prior show schedules
i was noticing that for example she
openly backfrack banning fracking like
i do not understand how that is possibly
a good idea when pennsylvania's up for
grabs
yeah i mean so look i think i think
harris is probably the the worst
or the least bad of the picks i actually
kind of nurse a theory that biden was
ready to go with karen bass a few weeks
ago until
uh the castro and scientology stuff uh
broke and that's why we got a delay in
the the
vetting process or in in the veep
announcement
but you know you have you had susan rice
who brings benghazi baggage
you had keisha lance bottoms who is the
mayor
of atlanta i actually thought val
demings was a solid choice
but she's just a house member so there
was just not a lot of depth in the pic
um but yeah she's gonna open up some
avenues of attack on biden
so you know looking at the the future of
the race how much do you think that the
trump campaign is gonna focus on biden
per se and how much do you think they're
going to focus
on harris they've been having some
trouble getting their arms around biden
because he's been able to essentially
hide in in the basement not do a lot of
interviews be somewhat
pat in his answers even when he's made a
boo-boo it's been quickly covered up by
the media so even when he said
a week ago that all black people think
the same which is it seems kind of
racist to me
that that kind of went away from the
headlines after about 24 hours
how much do you think the trump campaign
is going to you know load its guns and
go after
harris as opposed to going after biden
yeah bobby's a tough target uh for trump
quite frankly uh
because whatever else you say you know
the two templates you run against
a democrat are there their elitist
intellectuals
uh you know pointy-headed intellectuals
or they're
you know liberal fanatics and whatever
you want to say about biden he's
definitely not a pointy-headed
intellectual
um and it was hard to pin the liberal
fanatic on him because he's always been
right dead in the center of the
democratic party so i think harris
probably now enables the trump campaign
to paint biden is further
left than he is and of course biden's
old everyone knows that there's a
reasonable chance that
that his vice president becomes
president so i do think there's going to
be some more scrutiny of the vice
president than typical
now on the other side there have been
questions about kamala harris maybe not
being progressive
enough so it doesn't matter that she's
endorsed a wide variety of wild leftist
policies doesn't matter that she's got
you know the support of the bernie
sanders
uh wing a little bit the fact is that
she was pretty unpopular with that wing
of the party when she ran
in the primaries particularly because of
her law enforcement pass because she
started off as a prosecutor
in california she has a long and
controversial history of doing things
like increasing
the prosecution of of truancy and
meanwhile joe biden of course is one of
the chief sponsors of the 1994 crime
bill do you think that there's going to
be any gap that opens up
between the progressive side of the
party and the and the biden
harris wing of the party on law and
order or do you think that everything
sort of gets patched over for the sake
of beating trump
yeah i think i think the latter most
likely um i think
uh there's probably some people who are
disappointed it wasn't warren
uh some people who were probably still
holding out hopes for bernie
as the vice president but uh at the end
of the day i i think
you know their hatred for trump is so
visceral uh that they would be able to
overlook quite a bit
uh in a vice presidential uh selection
alrighty so sean let's look at the
electoral map
right now right now it appears that the
race seems to be kind of tightening not
on national level on a national level it
seems like biden is still up by
somewhere between six and eight points
in most of the polls
it seems like it's tightened a little
bit from when he was up nearly double
digits uh
it also seems i've been noticing that
joe biden cannot break 50 percent with a
hammer
uh he he's up at 49. trump is down at 40
and it's pretty reminiscent of a lot of
the polls against hillary clinton where
hillary
was beating him by 10 points during most
of the race but
she was never able to break 50 she was
just stuck up at 48 49 percent
trump could theoretically finish four
points back in the popular vote and
still win this thing
the same thing could hold true here and
it seems like things are tightening in a
variety of battleground states as well
both in trump's favor and against trump
where do you think things stand right
now
i i think it has tightened uh nationally
a couple points look
a month ago it really looked like this
thing was getting away from trump and
people were starting to talk about
democrats
maybe getting 55 senators you know
something like that
um and so it is significant that he
seems to have stanced the bleeding and
even made up a couple grounds if he's
down
seven points eight points nationally he
can probably lose the popular vote
by three or four points and win the
presidency in the electoral college and
as you said
a lot of these battleground states uh
the polls do seem to be tightening and
it looks like realistically it's a three
or four point race
which is something i think trump can
make up so
looking at the at the map right now if
you are the biden campaign obviously
you're focusing on you know ohio and
florida but there's also been talk about
them opening up the campaign as wide as
georgia and texas
where would you be putting your
resources if you were the biden campaign
and conversely if you're trump
where would you put in your resources
right now because he's got a lot of
ground to defend
if i were the biden campaign i would be
skeptical about taking texas until i was
pretty sure uh
that i had all my ducks in a row and was
going to win and was kind of going for a
knockout blow if you will
i would put money into georgia um
especially since there's two
senate races there uh that you could
possibly pad your margin the senate and
actually be able to get something done
as president
um but but you know ultimately this is
an election that's going to be won or
lost in arizona wisconsin michigan
pennsylvania florida and that's where i
think the resources have to be
uh concentrated at this point telling me
sean trendy
of real clear politics so sean looking
at sort of your crystal ball i'm not
asking you to call the election
quite this early is there enough time
for trump to make up the ground to win
this election what needs to change
between now
and the election for trump to vault
himself back into a re-elect
bid and overall do you think that the
kamala harris pick hurts
helps biden or kind of leaves things
where they were
yeah i think there's plenty i think
there's like i said he only has to
make up about four points which is
adding two points to his total and
taking two points away from biden and i
think that's
that's doable uh someone made a comment
back in like
i think it was april that if the dow was
above 30 000 and unemployment was in the
single digits then trump wins
and i think that's not a bad way to look
at it if it's clear
the economy is improving if this kind of
summer blip we're seeing
and covid goes away and things look okay
in the fall
i think there's a good chance he'll be
uh re-elected as for harris
i don't think she particularly uh hurts
or harms i think she opens up some lines
of attack on biden
ultimately though i do think people will
vote for president and not vice
president well maybe in the end that's
all that biden could have hoped for out
of this pick considering
that he is perceived widely as as
vulnerable
and he didn't want to give you know
every line of attack to his opponent by
picking you know karen bass that would
have opened up the communist line of
attack which he sort of wanted to avoid
sean trendy from real club politics
really appreciate the time and the
insight
thank you it's kamala harris that is joe
biden's pick for vice president because
apparently he was still in some sort of
induced coma
when he decided to make this pick i do
not see the logic behind it it makes no
sense to me
it is a pure play for twitter blue
checks and for the
historic veneer that's all this is and
the all the headlines today are black
women nominated for vp that's all he was
looking for
the problem is that she is not a good
candidate she's a very very bad
candidate she has a ton of
vulnerabilities not only that
she has gone after him personally she
said for example that she believes
accusers
that joe biden made them feel
uncomfortable right she believes his
sexual harassment accusers this was
kamala harris last year guys last year
does anyone have a memory
longer than that of a guppy here is
kamala harris last year
i believe them and i i respect um
them being able to tell their story and
having the courage to do it
do you believe that the vice president
should enter this race
oh he's gonna have to make that decision
for himself i wouldn't tell him what to
do
she was calling on him i mean that's her
telling him to leave the race isn't it
and that that's who kamala harris is and
then he picked that
uh get a food taster mr vice president
get a food taster like
asap asap now you'll also remember
that kamala harris was the delightful
type of person
who had suggested that she would ban
fracking they should get rid of your
private insurance
that she would get rid of plastic straws
she said that she could ban assault
weapons by executive order in open
debate
she has said in public amicus briefs
that the freedom of religion
should basically be reserved to the
private sphere that is the thing that
she has
absolutely said and she is
a disaster area she's a disaster area
and yet the media love her they're
they're going to treat her with kids
now here's the thing they didn't love
her when she was running as soon as she
dropped out then they were like oh man
isn't it sad that kamala harris is gone
she's awesome like i we should really
we're gonna miss her aren't we
well yeah no no nobody missed her but
she's back anyway
is she a radical you bet your ass she's
a radical here is kamala harris
comparing ice to the kkk
i do not see a parallel between what is
constitutionally mandated as
as it relates to enforcing the law are
you aware that there's a perception
are you aware that there's a perspective
ice in the same category as the kkk
is that what you're asking me no i'm
very specific about what i'm asking
are you aware of a perception that the
way
that the discretion i see i'm not
finished i see none
i'm not finished i'm not finished are
you aware that there's a perception
that that ice is administering
its power in a way that is causing fear
i mean that's amazing that's amazing so
she compared ice to the kkk
and then she was like well i'm not
saying that they're like that but are
you aware that there are people who are
afraid of ice
also she backs illegal immigrants
receiving medicare so that's that's an
exciting thing
so everybody's health care should be
paid for by the american taxpayer
including people who are here legally
here is
kamala hair saying that's a jake tapper
every individual who is a resident of
the united states is entitled to
benefits for health care services under
this act
not every individual who's a citizen but
every individual who's a resident
so you support giving universal
healthcare medicare for all to people
who are in this country illegally
let me just be very clear about this i
am opposed to any policy
that would deny in our country any human
being
from access to public safety
public education or public health period
also she backs 70 tax rates so if you
think the tax rates where you live are
already too high
wait until you get a load of kamala
harris endorsing aoc's 70
top tax bracket is something she did on
the view when megan mccain asked her
about it
and she's promoting policies like saying
that every single carbon emission in the
country every car
should be eliminated within the next 11
years everything from a 70 to 80 percent
tax rate
do you agree that she could possibly in
this ideology of the socialist
left could splinter your party no you
know
i think that um she is
challenging the status quo i think
that's fantastic
i think i think that she is introducing
bold
ideas that that should be discussed
and i think it's good for the party i
frankly think it's good for the country
let's look at the bold ideas let's look
at those bold ideas like 70
tax rates by the way she was a senate
endorser of aoc's green new deal
resolution
was kamala harris and that's putting
aside the fact that she's an
unbelievably incompetent campaigner i
mean incredibly incompetent
it's also putting aside the fact that
she's routinely and
and viciously machiavellian
remember that time she went after brett
kavanaugh so there are a few things she
did during that brett kavanaugh hearing
that were just
just despicable and during the brett
kavanaugh hearing she literally
presented republicans with a letter
signed by a woman named jane doe
alleging that brett kavanaugh raped her
in the back of a car
there were no details there's no
explanation of who the woman was there
was no way for them to actually pin down
any of the allegations
harris just passed along that letter
washington times reported that
also she questioned kavanaugh in the
most nasty possible
fashion i mean she was awful during the
kavanaugh hearings lest you forget
heroes kamala hair is trying to make a
name for herself during the kavanaugh
hearings
the only difference is that you have
been accused of sexual assault
how do you reconcile your statement
about a conspiracy against you
with the treatment of someone who was
before this body not very long ago
do you agree that it is possible for men
to both be friends with some women
and treat other women badly did you um
watch
dr ford's testimony
i did not i planned i plan i mean she
she was just awful just an awful person
just an awful person
and she does not underscore joe biden as
nice guy
and she is waiting in the wings and
everybody knows she is waiting in the
wings
so honestly if i were trump and i had
biden in a debate
i'd basically just dismiss him i would
my strategy would be pretty simple
joe biden gets up there and he says
don't worry i'm uh
you're trying to malign me and saying
i'm getting rid of social security and
i'm radical i'm not
i'm old joe biden and if i were trump i
would say
i'm not worried about you i don't think
you're going to be around for a second
term
i'm worried about your vp that's it
straight out that's what everybody's
thinking
the only reason anyone cares about
kamala harris is because everyone
assumes
joe biden is not filling out two terms
and i think they are correct in this
assumption
59 percent of americans according to new
rasmussen polls think that kamala harris
will end up as president
if joe biden is elected within the first
term not within two terms within
one term okay she is a
she's a radical she is extraordinarily
incompetent
she opens up so many avenues of attack
for the trump campaign they must be just
salivating at this point there's a lady
who tweeted
back in april of 2017 quote an
undocumented immigrant is not a criminal
she said we should decriminalize border
crossings by the way and if you think
that trump is going to lay off of kamala
harris's start in politics namely the
fact
that she originally got a career boost
by being the girlfriend of willie brown
you are wrong
donald trump ain't gonna lay off that
for one single solitary segment not not
for a second
not for a second if you didn't know that
tiana lowe writes for the washington
examiner
she points out that that willie brown
who spent a quarter of a century is that
in fact a royalty in california he was
three decades as a member of the
california assembly and eight mayors
eight years as mayor of san francisco
once carried out an open extra marital
affair with a young prosecutor
named kamala harris when harris was 30
she began dating brown he was in his 60s
brown was married at the time also
according to according to reporting from
the
san francisco weekly aside from handing
her an expensive bmw brown appointed
kamala harris to two patronage positions
in state government that paid handsomely
more than four hundred thousand dollars
over five years
in 1994 she took a six-month leave of um
of absence from her alameda county job
to join the unemployment insurance
appeals board brown then appointed her
to the california medical assistance
commission
where she served until 1998 attending
two meetings a month for a 99
000 annual salary so um
do you think that that donald trump
leaves that stone unturned does that
seem like your style
does that seem like your style i think
not i have serious doubts
meanwhile there is a lot of news on
kamala harris's long cop history
so the left really is not fond of kamala
harris because some people on the really
hardcore progressive left
see her as too harsh in her prosecutions
reason magazine has good coverage of
this
reason magazine pointed out is back in
june of 2019.
during her 28-year tenure as a county
prosecutor district attorney and state
attorney general
harris proved quite willing to live up
to the epithet that she was a cop
in the public eye she spoke of racial
justice and liberal values bolstering
her cred as one of the democratic
party's rising stars behind closed doors
she repeatedly fought for more
aggressive prosecution not just to
violent criminals but of people who
committed misdemeanors and quality of
life crimes
over and over again harris went beyond
the call of duty fighting for harsher
sentences
larger bail requirements longer prison
terms more prosecution of petty crimes
greater criminal justice involvement in
low-income and minority communities less
due process
for people in the system less
transparency and less accountability for
bad cops
all of this according to reason magazine
they also point out that she was
personally selected for her position at
the california medical assistance
commission by willie brown
who was her boyfriend and again that was
not the first time he had given her a
lucrative state appointment which is
one hell of a way to enter public
service
so she went back to san francisco she
became a d.a over there and there
she apparently started arresting truants
she made a bit of a name for herself by
arresting
students and then trying to leverage
them according to jim garrity
over at national review harris pushed
for a statewide law in california that
lets prosecutors charge parents with
misdemeanors
if their children are chronically truant
we're putting parents on notice she
declared
if you fail in your responsibility to
your kids we're going to work to make
sure you face the full force and
consequences of the law you'll remember
this was a line of attack used
famously by tulsi gabbard the
representative from hawaii
in debates with kamala harris harris had
no answer whatsoever
harris has been a strong advocate of
civil asset forfeiture which is a bill
that would have allowed prosecutors to
seize the assets before they even
initiate
criminal proceedings as san francisco
district attorney harris created
a program called back on track the
program received 750 000
in federal funding but faced criticism
because an illegal immigrants who pled
guilty to selling drugs was selected
and graduated from the back on track
program only later
to grab a woman's purse and run her down
in an suv severely injuring her
so there's a lot of dirt on this lady
like a lot of dirt on her
she also happens to be incredibly
nasty with regard to with regard to
religious institutions
kamala harris not only refused to
represent the people of california
in defending traditional marriage she
also
filed a she also filed a
an amicus brief harris did
on religious liberty in california
in which she suggested that the
in which she suggested that religious
liberty ought to be
restricted largely and almost solely to
the private sphere
which should scare everybody who cares
about religious liberty terence jeffrey
writing back in march of 2019
points out that
barack obama in in pushing obamacare
tried to issue a regulation requiring
health insurance plans to cover
sterilizations
and fda approved contraceptive methods
this would include
for various catholic
businesses and christian owned
businesses
harris wrote a an amicus brief in a case
called hobby lobby
that was a closely owned family
corporation that argued that
they should not be forced to cover abort
abortion care because they were a
christian-owned company
kamala harris was a g of california she
wrote a brief to the supreme court
in her brief she suggested free exercise
of religion
is a right created by man-made statutes
and is a personal thing that should be
kept in an inner sanctum here's what she
wrote quote
rights to the free exercise of religious
beliefs whether created by statute or by
the constitution
likewise protect the development and
expression of an inner sanctum of
personal religious faith
free exercise rights have also have thus
also been understood as personal
relating only to individual believers
and to a limited class of associations
comprising or representing them
unsurprisingly she continued there is no
tradition no
tradition of recognizing or
accommodating the exercise of such
inherently personal rights
by ordinary for-profit business
corporations
only religious institutions supposedly
would
would be covered here
but that is not what the first amendment
says so she
cited against hobby lobby and she she's
a she's a
wild radical and i look forward to her
answering some tough questions
because joe biden isn't frankly i look
forward to the base between her and my
pens
i think that she is rehearsed i think
she honestly i if you're the trump
campaign you got to be happy today you
got to be happy today
it's a bad pick it's a bad pick
and by the way if biden and harris enter
the white house
then the governor of california gets to
pick who the next senator
to fill that seat is so get ready for
adam schiff
or antonio viaragosa as senator from
california maybe karen bass
so that'll be lots and lots of fun it is
kamala harris
it is kamala harris so look
here's the good news america is an
amazing country i mean the fact is that
two immigrants came to the united states
one from jamaica one from india they met
they had a kid that kid could be vice
presidents of the united states i mean
that's an amazing american success story
too bad america is obviously
systemically evil and racist according
to most of the democratic party because
otherwise
things like that could happen in america
the bad news for the biden campaign
is that kamal harris is terrible and not
only is kamala harris terrible she spent
most of the campaign attacking joe biden
this is what happens when you let when
you let the twitterverse dictate to you
how you should run your campaign joe
biden you idiot like seriously it's
amazing
joe biden avoids the big boo boo the
entire race
he avoids the big booboo of listening to
the twitterverse he ignores them
he doesn't give them any credence he
sits in the basement he shows up just
barely alive at the debates
he waits for bernie sanders to emerge as
the frontrunner and then he's like
really that old commie
and then he wins and then the one big
decision he has left
he picks one of the least popular
democratic candidates in the field who
also happens to be extraordinarily
off-putting and radical but
simultaneously pisses off the
progressives in the base because she was
a narc so well done
joe biden very very solid stuff
bottom line is that democrats are
basically hoping just to do this and
move on
i do not think that is that is the way
this is going to work i do not think
that's the way this is
going to work at all in fact i think
this is going to be the lead
point of the attack for trump's campaign
in a debate with biden i think trump
very obviously just goes right for the
jugular i think that biden says
something
and right off the bat trump says you
know what it doesn't matter what you say
because you ain't gonna be president
right we all know it the american people
know it you're not with it joe
you don't look good you're already too
old for this job
you know and if they want kanye harris
as president then they sure didn't show
it before
but you picked her and uh and so i don't
believe your protestations of moderation
i don't even think she needs to push it
i just think she needs to wait
and donald trump will say that and he
will be correct 59 percent of americans
by gallup polls believe
that kamala harris finishes joe biden's
for como harris finishes joe biden's
first term
and she is it's not an obvious pick
not an obvious pick at all frankly and
uh i'm
i'm kind of astonished at joe biden by
the way how radical
is kamal harris kamel harris is so
radical that at a certain point during
the debates joe biden was asked whether
by executive order he would ban assault
weapons okay first of all it's bad
policy
the assault weapons ban was utterly
ineffective and it doesn't have a good
definition but
put that aside joe biden at least had
the wherewithal to say
yeah i can't constitutionally just ban
assault weapons and kamala harris is
like constitution
what constitution cute insane joker
laugh here is kamala harris
you can't do it by executive order any
more than trump can do things
when he says he can do it by executive
order does the vice president have a
point there
some things you can many things you
can't let's let the senator answer
well i mean i would just say hey joe
instead of saying no we can't let's say
yes we can
let's be constitutional we got to come
you ready for a lot of that you refer a
lot of that yep
remember that time that kamala harris
was selling shirts on her website that
said that little girl was me
and attacking biden from being a
segregationist that's who that guy
picked
that's who he picked slow joe you almost
feel bad for the guy a little bit
you almost feel a bit almost here is
kamala harris once more
the only clip that will be played for
the rest of the campaign kamala harris
ripping joe biden as a racist
segregationist who wanted to prevent her
from going to school
it's personal and it was actually very
it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race
in this country and it was not only that
but
you also worked with them to oppose
bussing
and you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bused to school every day
and that little girl was me oh
oh that little girl was kamala but now
the good news is
that they're best friends now guys like
america's an amazing place what a
rom-com this is it's pretty spectacular
yay they're all together again
had a weird ending you didn't see that
one coming did you and this is
it's a bold move cotton we'll see if it
pays off for him we will see if it pays
off
for him uh i i i have doubts i have
serious doubts
and again if you're in the trump
campaign you've got to be happy today
you have got to be very pleased he will
get one day of good headlines out of
this and then the rest of the campaign
he is going to have to deal with that as
his pick
that that's going to be the the entire
thing
of all the people they went they decided
to pick they went for
the old white guy the democrats and a
person the progressives believe is a cop
who happens to be radical and undercuts
biden's claims of moderation
well points for uh points for audacity
if not a lot of points for brains
alrighty we'll be back here tomorrow to
recap
all of this we will bring you all of the
fallout from joe biden's
fabulous kamala harris picking by
fabulous i mean terrible you're
listening to the venture hero show
[Music]